welcome to the wonderful and dreary
world of greed fall where you play as a
user created character and a fantastical
version of the seventeenth century
throughout your adventure you'll explore
a remote island chat with natives and
grow your influence as you attempt to
cure a mysterious illness the skills
attributes and abilities your character
has are yours to choose but if you're
feeling a bit overwhelmed by it all
we're here to help you get off to a good
start here are seven tips to hit the
ground running in greed fall number one
talents act as skill checks like most
role-playing games greed fall has its
fair share of skill trees when you start
your adventure you will need to pick a
talent these include charisma science
intuition vigor craftsmanship and
lock-picking these essentially act as
skill checks as you level up you'll be
able to invest in each of these trees
however keep in mind that you will only
have one talent point to spend at the
beginning this means there are certain
options and areas will be locked out of
in the beginning of greed fall for
example the owner of a bar wants you to
fix his furniture or give him money to
repair it based on what your cousin has
done if you do not have craftsmanship
level 1 then you can't really repair
them despite being allowed to pick that
option you can reset your points with
memory crystals but you won't have a ton
of those in the beginning keep these
things in mind when deciding which
talents you choose number to focus on
lock-picking
while all of these talents are useful we
found that there are a lot of locked
doors in chests in the first area of the
city of serene and because you won't be
able to return to serene after the
tutorial you probably won't want to miss
out on the extra items and loot hidden
and locked chests there are also some
runes you happen upon rather early in
the game and you're required to open
three chests to continue through them so
if you don't have the lock picking skill
or some spare keys then you'll have to
backtrack or reset your talents focus on
the pistol two swords or cool button
greed for the pistol is way better
pistols can do a ton of damage to enemy
armor and can knock foes back pistols
are also useful against enemy
ceil encounter swords don't do nearly as
much damage and sometimes they can't
even penetrate enemy armor you can buy
pistol ammo from merchants so make sure
you're stocked up I'd also recommend
leveling up the pistol skills sooner
rather than later number four don't
discredit your teammates in some games
your teammates suck and don't do much
for you however in greed fall I'd argue
your teammates can sometimes be better
than you I've been in situations where
my team and I have been ambushed by four
to five monsters and my teammates took
care of the majority of them keep this
in mind when deciding who you want on
your team and how you want to build your
relationship with them you'll be able to
check their skills attributes and other
details about them before picking them -
just a heads up that you can only have
two people on your party at a time
so pick wisely number 5 look for
campsites the island of Tier four D is
massive and it can take a while to get
from point A to point B fortunately
there is fast travel as you explore the
world keep an eye out for camp sites
these act as hubs that let you swap out
your gear rest and of course fast travel
when you first land in Tier four D
you'll get a quest that will ask you to
map the island by finding campsites and
other points of interest this is a good
way to track how many camp sites are in
each area keep in mind that you can't
fast travel at any time you need to be
at a camp or a globe number six loyalty
missions taken right out of a Bioware
game greed fall features loyalty
missions
these are personal quests designed
specifically around one of your
teammates upon completing one of these
quests your bond with that teammate will
increase you'll want to keep these bonds
high because if you piss off a friend
too much they might abandon your crew
altogether so make sure to check on your
teammates often number seven fury and
tactical pause combat can be tough and
greed fall especially if you're under
leveled
however there are some techniques and
strategies you'll want to know first pay
attention to your fury meter as you cast
spells attack and counter you'll build
fury you can then unleash your fury by
pulling right trigger this move deals a
significant amount of damage and can
knock your enemies off balance
greed fall also has something called
tactical pause this allows you to pause
combat and let you pick your next move
you probably won't need to use this all
that often but we found it useful during
the trickier fights if you need to heal
or pick the right spell use tactical
pause hopefully these tips helped you
get started on your journey through tier
4 d are there any other tips you thought
of that might help out fellow travelers
leave them in the comments below and
thank you so much for watching
[Music]
you
[Music]